Hello, hello, hello,
hello, welcome in, welcome in, welcome in,
welcome in, oh, sorry, here's my mouse, welcome back to Silent Hill, if, wait, hold on, I didn't actually, I didn't actually do any, like, sound stuff, I just started streaming, I forgot, professional,
Professional streamer.
I sound quiet.
I should sound the exact same.
That's not the thing that I was talking about.
Thank you for the great concert.
I also started painting a figure.
The game sounds louder.
Wait, what?
Really?
Is that better?
I don't know.
I don't...
I shouldn't sound.
I can't tell.
What's it called?
The little...
Oh, here we go.
It's better now?
Okay.
Am I always quiet?
I'm not good at this kind of stuff.
Like the hills.
You're silent.
is low but that's old i'm i'm better now right don't apologize thank you i'm usually perfect okay cool i have to max your streams seriously but okay here i'll give you guys like kind of uh hold on so what i just sounded like I always try to hit like the sweet spot in OBS.
Hold on, I'm saving a picture.
OBS.
When I do sound, I try to hit like right in the middle of the yellow so I'm not like peaking in red.
That sweet spot, I feel like that's a sweet spot, no?
Huh.
You need some headroom for screaming.
I know, that's how I feel.
Sometimes I'm, like, really quiet.
Sometimes I'm quiet, but sometimes I get really...
Sometimes I get loud, so I try to, like...
Kind of keep a balance a little bit.
Hello.
I don't know.
I guess I could...
Hold on.
I guess I could afford to put my gains up a tiny bit for my mic one second listening to okay okay making Halloween cookies that sounds so awesome let's
test it here today and if this is if this sounds good I could keep it as like this okay dokey last time we ended we um we uh wrinkle got sent to hell and And, um, Sakuko, we locked her in the dark.
We locked her in my mine dungeon.
And, um, we are about to go into shoes.
Whatever is going on.
Whatever is going on with him.
That's where we last ended off.
So...
Actually, I also thought...
I want to change my costume today.
I don't know where my white costume went.
Why did my DLC get taken away from me?
Today we are bunny.
Guys, I have a confession.
Maybe other stuff on YouTube, like ads that make...
Wait, that's not live, make their videos as loud as possible without peaking.
Wait, what?
that wait huh huh I don't understand sorry um okay I have a bit of a confession um I okay so the school was so scary and now I think okay here's like my issue with long horror games is eventually you're gonna get like kind of used to the atmosphere and then it becomes not so scary and then it just becomes more action and that's when it's like kind of boring for me i feel like horror games usually like like it's usually better the shorter they are when it turns into a chore i almost was just like i don't feel like i'm gonna But I almost,
I, I was like thinking the other day, I was just like, I'm just, I don't know.
I, I, the thing is, is I really like, I really like the atmosphere and I like so far what's been going on.
But I think, you know, I just, for me, truly, for like horror games, and I mean, Silent Hill has always been this way.
I just don't favor action in my horror games.
I prefer it to be more atmospheric than anything.
And I think this game has so many stinking monsters that you have to deal with in this game.
So, that's just my opinion.
Obviously, like, you know, if you prefer action in your horror games, that's totally cool for you.
the enemies are just damaged sponges too yeah i saw i saw a tweet pop up in my timeline of someone being like if there is a story mode or story like yes i think is i think when i'm on a story mode for a game i shouldn't be dealing with souls bosses and i was like i think this has to do with silent hill i was like um not that i'm I haven't found it like super challenging it's just that I for horror I'm not wanting an action experience I'm wanting like to be immersed in the atmosphere and getting creeped out and everything so like I said I'm no quitter I'm not gonna drop the game but I'm just wanted to be honest with you guys kind of like my thoughts on on where i'm kind of standing like uh because i was i like i said i was pretty close to being like i don't think i'm gonna play it today i'm just not in the mood but at the same time at the same time i do want to see where it goes
so horror games shouldn't be longer than eight hours at most yeah see i i agree i agree i think Horror games in particular should be shorter.
Unless it's like kind of like, I guess, you know, there are some horror games where it's like they take on the action a little bit more.
Like, I guess like this.
But I don't know.
I think if your main focus is the horror and the atmosphere, shorter is way better.
Resident Evil 4 was way too long.
I don't even consider that.
Well, actually, one of the reasons I did not.
play Resident Evil for so long is because I always considered it an action series.
I did not think it was scary at all.
And so I wasn't interested.
And then Seven came out and I was like, oh, okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
I guess because Silent Hill is also like survival horror, it's kind of its own genre as well but at the same time the atmosphere in this game has been so good and now i'm just kind of feeling like i see an enemy and i'm like it's not so much that i'm like you know i don't know but yeah so that's just a kind of how I'm feeling at the moment.
You can run past the enemies if you want.
That's true, that's true.
And in some cases, you really have to.
Luckily, they don't, they kind of give up the chase pretty fast, so.
But I just wanted to kind of share where my brain was at with the game right now.
Like I said, I don't know.
I'm like conflicted.
I'm conflicted because I want to like it and I do but at the same time I'm just kind of like you'd probably like fatal frame I love fatal frame I love fatal frame actually uh Koei Tecmo they put out like a thing the other day being like we're looking for creators who would be interested in the fatal frame 2 remake and I sent in my information it was my first time ever doing that i've never had the chance to like you know when when companies like that are searching for creators in the past i was never able to and so this was my first time ever ever doing it so i was kind of like and i kept calling this game fatal frame anyway i love i really love fatal frame
so yeah like i said i still want to finish this game but probably we'll just do i have a question because i know that this game requires multiple playthroughs should be scary when enemies show up not annoying or tiring yeah yeah i have a question for this for for like the second how many playthroughs do you have it requires four to five playthroughs oh what i thought it was like three two to three four to what the heck oh my gosh at least three okay that's what I was seeing was three
um three minimum I had 30 I heard three to four oh for for the playthroughs is it something that like you know how when you for okay how do I explain um for some alternate endings to games you can just like watch like the ending on YouTube you know you can just look it up but for for this game do things change throughout the story like do things kind of like little are there little details that are different for those who know obviously oh it does stuff does change some of the cut scenes change Ah.
It changes some scenes.
Collectibles are different.
Ah, I see, I see, I see.
I see, I see.
Small changes.
They explicitly tell you stuff that they only hinted at previously.
Okay, okay, okay.
Interesting.
It is a big commitment, though.
It makes it tough as a streaming game.
It dies.
I'm not going to lie.
Let's get into it.
Okay, Shu, what do you got going on in here?
Wait, hold on.
That's my full health at the top.
I got four bandages.
This is lock.
Dodge.
Small.
Big.
Okay.
All right.
Oh.
See, I see you over there, and I'm like, gosh, dang it.
The medicine cabinet from Shoe's place.
Okie dokie.
That's okay.
That's right.
It's like these puzzly thingies again where we open stuff and then...
What is it?
Oh, this was the room.
That's right.
Where she like crossed out.
Rinko crossed out my picture.
In my times, games are simple with only one ending.
hating on multiple endings obviously i'm not even hating on i'm not even hating on having to
replay a game to get multiple endings oh oh my gosh oops wait that's not what i wanted to do wait how did i there we go yeah did
you come from oh okay no it's just it's just getting angry from behind.
I got it.
Yeah, get out of here.
Ugly.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
It's going to come back to life.
I got to get out of here.
There's so many enemies in this game.
Where are you going?
Sorry.
I'm going to...
Okay, so this is where the red will shut.
Okay.
Okie dokie.
Where?
Right there?
It looks like it.
The music in this game is so good.
Wee!
Where are you leading me?
Ah, okay.
And this one changes it.
I wish there was a blue light room.
Sakuko's area.
It was so nice for that.
Why are my pigtails the most adorable thing ever?
Thanks, I think so too.
Silent Hill had multiple endings.
You know, I guess it was so long ago that I played Silent Hill.
I mean, I played three.
That was the last one I played.
And I think that was like...
when did Silent Hill when was Silent Hill 3 released let's see I'm checking Silent Hill 3 okay no it was definitely several years after it was definitely several years after it said it was released in 2003 wait was that in is that Japanese or I don't know Hmm.
But, uh...
Fun!
Fun, fun, fun, fun, fun, fun, fun, fun.
I don't want to get jump scared anymore.
I'm tired.
Where'd she go?
A freakazoid.
Any items?
Not that I can carry much.
Where'd she go?
Sorry, I know I keep checking the map over and over.
I'm tired, boss.
Where'd she go?
She's not above.
Gamers don't look up?
Freakazoid bottom, right?
Okay, I'm just gonna go.
Oh wait, there's more?
No, that's a wall.
That is a wall, right?
It's a wall!
Drawing of a young Shimizu Hinako.
Tonari no Seki no Shimizu Hinako.
Baka.
Oh, wasn't the- What was that?
Wait, what was that manga?
Tonari no Seki no something.
Oh, what was the guy's name?
Nice uniform, Hinako.
Something you could wear to a wedding.
What the...
Seki-kun!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Even if it was drawn by an elementary school student, it's still too bad.
Oh my gosh.
Don't quit your day job, Shu.
This is definitely drawn on purpose.
What?
I don't think it looks that bad.
I think it...
Actually, for elementary school, I think this looks really good.
good there are all kinds of curses written on it such as stupid disgusting etc well actually it only says stupid and disgusting there is no etc this is a prized possession he hates me okay i'm ready to oh this thing is gonna jump at me
It's too quiet.
I think it's a coffee ground.
Sorry.
I got, there's like a local coffee place and they buy me and they added some new stuff.
And they wrote thank you on my...
Okay.
This is how I know it was made for me.
They wrote thank you on my cup.
But in the O of the thank you, they made it into a P sign.
And I was like, Metal Gear!
Why is it so quiet?
Okay, cool.
I'm barking, yes.
I gotta keep them away somehow.
Okay, prized possession.
Number two.
Oh, my shadow scared me!
I thought something was sneaking up behind me!
Oh, spooky scary!
Spooky scary.
What?
Why?
Why, all of a sudden?
Is it the one we saw from earlier?
Oh, okay.
Music disappears.
Okay.
I think it is.
The one from earlier.
Ooh.
Music is so creepy.
Ah!
Come here.
And dodge!
And...
Uh-oh.
Oh shoot, wait.
Don't dodge the wrong way.
Don't kill me, please.
Oh, yikes, yikes, yikes.
Oops, wrong thing.
Wait, I meant to do this.
Oh, no, we got another one!
Oh, shoot.
I messed up.
I did a whoopsie.
Another?
Oh, it's the one from earlier.
okay oh we got an emma oh my gosh we can now upgrade some stuff and a divine water dang i messed up what's in here the scent of herbs herbs is overpowering okay let's see oh oh it's underneath whoa where are we going Shoo!
Stinky herbs.
Anything?
Oh, ah!
We were rewarded.
Wait, uh, I still have three.
It's not bad.
Yo-kang.
Nice.
I will eat that up.
You're not gonna like this next room though.
Oh, why?
Don't say that!
This one coming up!
I wish I could sa- Oh!
I was about to say I wish I could save!
The game just auto-saved for me.
Let's go.
Why am I not gonna like it?
Oh!
Squelchery.
Whoa!
Is this a boss?
Uh-oh!
Whoa.
Let me see her face pretty.
Oh.
A baby.
Oh, boy.
Oh, defeat the monsters.
Great.
Love this.
I'll focus on that thing.
Never mind.
Ah!
Oh!
Never mind.
Does it explode?
Oh, it explodes into...
Oh, gosh.
Oh, no!
Please!
Um.
Wait, I want to focus on...
This thing is more... Wait, no, please.
This one.
There we go.
No!
Dodge!
Oh my god.
Uh, it keeps focusing... Okay, it's like focusing on both of them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I just couldn't... Oh, geez.
Oh my gosh!
This is kind of brutal.
Okay.
Ooh, nice dodge.
Good job, man.
Um...
Oh.
Okay, I got it.
Oh, wait, was that not close enough to the...
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, okay, okay, okay.
She's a big boy.
Oh, shoot!
Oh, geez.
Ouch, how much my arm!
Okay, come here.
Come here, nasty.
Okay, back.
Oh my gosh!
Ow!
Oh, it got, like, cornered.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Ah, I tried!
I wasn't fast enough!
Okay, I can't see the other thing, please.
There we go.
Ugh!
Oh my gosh!
Nice sir!
Please die!
Please die.
Ouchie ouch.
No more sanity!
Poker.
I am.
Ouchie ouchie!
Ouchie!
Maybe I can...
Oh, dang it.
Oh, geez.
Not good.
Not reading her inputs like at all.
Oh, gross.
I'm not...
I'm not doing so hot, guys.
More babies!
Yeah.
And dodge!
Dodge!
I can't see!
I can't see where the other thing is because it's like the lock-on is so... icky.
Dodge, dodge, dodge!
Please!
I was too...
She's like so slow sometimes with her movements that like I try to attack and then dodge and I'm bad.
Okay.
Alright, back onto you.
Why?
Oh, my god.
Yes.
Uh, shoot.
Misanity.
Okay.
Yeah.
Try!
Yeah!
A monster covered in swollen, skin-crawling mounds.
Each one pulses.
It spawns more and more horrors.
What a vile show of life.
I'd rather die than turn into a monster.
monster like this.
Yippee!
What else is in here?
Were there any items at all?
This one sucks on hard mode, I can imagine.
I can imagine a lot of these really sucking on hard mode.
There's nothing in here!
Stingy.
Stingy game.
Oh, wait.
Capsules.
Really?
Nothing else?
Okay.
Nothing?
Just capsules?
I guess they give you bandages before the fight.
I'm just looking at the room now.
It's kind of cool.
Okie dokie.
This is...
Yeah.
Uh, wait.
My health is...
Where are we?
Oh, we're...
Oh, neat.
Oh.
Are those going to spawn into...
Those are going to probably spawn into, like...
What's it called?
Right?
Into nasties?
Jinako is clearly on the death, death, death camp instead of the birth, birth, birth one.
Oh, I do have full... Wait, which... Hold on.
What does... What does this do?
Arare does... Health!
We'll eat.
We'll eat that.
Oh, like barely anything.
That's okay.
I know it's gonna explode.
Oh, it sounds so gross.
Yeah, see?
I'm already on the ready.
Oh, oops!
Oh, I killed it!
Let's go.
Let's...
I'll go around.
Wait, actually, maybe I should kill the other one just in case it spawns into something else too.
Kill, kill, kill.
Kill, death, death, death.
And also, I want to check this area.
I noticed that it was...
Eww!
Okay.
I noticed that it was blocked off, so I was like, I don't think I can come over here.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Oh!
Oh, wait, I have to come over here.
Oh, okay, okay.
Just kidding.
This is the way out.
Anything?
Oh, something.
No!
Brainiac Hero Comic.
The inside page was full of drawings.
Hinako were drawn in the bad guys that the protagonist defeated.
Wait, like an arrow pointing and saying Hinako?
We're pointed at the bad guys.
Moreover, in order to make the method of death even more bizarre than the manga's presentation they stubbornly added a lot of scattered blood and guts oh this is a wait i hear something though oh shoot i hate that these things can jump it's so evil oh okay yeah
oh my gosh they're wait they're everywhere though
wait where did it jump to behind me no Where did it- oh, it's over there, okay.
At least the blue light still works.
Oh my gosh.
This sucks.
Chomp, chomp, chomp, yummy, yummy, yummy.
Whoops, there we go.
Just stun looper?
Okay.
Easy.
Wait, there's more?
Why is the music still happening?
Just kidding.
Okay, now we go...
this way.
Where does this lead?
Ah!
Okay.
No one's gonna jump at me though, right?
Please.
I heard a fun fact today.
The fact is, Minto...
Quito!
Oishiko na'are, moe, moikyo.
Okie dokie.
Place the thing here?
Was there...
Oh, there it is.
Brainiac hero comic.
Oh, that area wasn't nearly as bad as I thought it would be.
Oh, dang!
Sure.
Wow.
I wanted to say you're cute today too.
Yobu, kawaii.
Aibo's not going to take care of you.
Hinako's so cold.
She's just like, okay, whatever.
What does that do?
Oh, oh, oh my god!
It doesn't look that tight.
I'm sorry.
Cold as ice.
The ice queen.
Oh, oh.
This guy is the baddie.
He's got to be.
Look,
I'll turn it up some.
Yeah,
why are we doing this?
The worst she could say is no.
She left him hanging like me.
mended to duck why are we still not over duck
happy happy birthday happy birthday
he just keeps on going the farewell party you have no place in my future
actually her dressed up as like the bunny if it's like us another silent hill reference that's one thing but also it's kind of like if if she's like a bunny she's like you know how bunny like you could like a bunny and the fox kind of situation is what it feels like a little too
fine shoe and linkle about me hold on though one second uh i wanted a proper property read your super chat a long time lurker of odd gang i have to send my tribute today thank you for being my kamiyoshi the year went by without your streams wait with sorry not without the year went by with your streams in the background while i worked thank you so much for karaoke and silent hill f in close proximity i'm a thank you so much thank you birthday um i've always despised who tell me how to act just because i'm a girl shu was different though he was the only person who ever understood me we were perfect partners i considered him a true companion as we got older the pressure from our parents got stronger even still shu never stopped treating me like his equal regardless of my gender there exists two hinako's inside me now sorry it's good there are two wolves inside you shimizu hinako whom i have known since birth and hinako And Hinako,
a woman who was trying to steal my body from the old man.
It's like an alien trying to take over me.
If this were space wars, my partner should be coming to the rescue.
But there's no sign of him.
Okay.
Onwards.
Into the mountains?
Did they go without me?
So rude.
Thank you so much for the super chat.
Thank you.
Good.
Give me out of here, please.
Imagine if they...
What?
If they made you decide, they're like, left or right.
Don't get it wrong.
What?
Do we have the abominable snowman up in here?
Oh wait, was that the smoke monster from the beginning?
Maybe.
Find a way to Shu's house.
Okay.
That's...
Wait, that's the school.
Uh, Shu's house is...
Over yonder?
Oh, all the way over there.
Okay.
I hope not.
She's so cute.
I would like to save.
It's a big map.
It is.
It is really big.
Bog Monster losing his patience.
Why?
He loses patience with me.
What's this?
Candies?
Chocolate?
That's where I came from, sorry.
La la la.
They're with the woods.
Is this the way...
Is this...
Is this like how far Shu had to walk every day from his home?
Because if so, that's the way torture.
Imagine having to walk back home.
All of these stairs?
Everything?
What's this?
Romani.
I thought I heard something in my room.
Um, I don't want...
We want some mushrooms, too?
No?
Save point.
What is that?
I'm just trying to get to the save point, please!
Uphill both ways For real Guy is the most fit person in town Let's see I have enough for health But I think maybe we'll save for more stamina Huh?
I also want a gotcha But I will resist He's pretty close to school, so it would be pretty chill.
Maybe, yeah.
I'll try that.
There we go.
Strange note.
I'm sorry.
Something urgent came up.
So I can't come with you.
Just trust me and continue down the path we decided.
I'll get everything ready and wait for you.
So there's...
Oh.
If I go straight...
Okay.
So over there is like a little shrine or something.
What am I hearing?
I'm gonna go over here.
And ignore that.
Oh!
Okay, let's go offer some stuff up.
Let's offer...
How much is chocolate?
Let's offer chocolate.
And Ramanay?
Yeah.
Buddy costume, what did I miss?
Actually, we haven't even been...
It's almost been an hour already.
Honestly, not that much has happened.
Wait, will this give me enough?
No.
Sad.
What do I need?
A thousand one hundred.
Okay.
1,100 for stamina.
Okay, alright.
So I have to go- wait.
Let's go get this.
Thank you.
And I will save one more time.
Just because I did all that stuff.
Okay, cool.
Showed my friend my- Wait.
The performance- wait.
Performance of Snake Kid from the show.
Now he's asking me where he can buy mid-bird?
What?!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for sharing.
Oh, he's up there!
I just... wait, what is to the left though?
What's over here?
A little exploration?
Oh, I don't... I don't trust that.
I don't trust that at all.
Uh...
Is it gonna wake up?
I just wanna go off for this.
Please don't wake up.
Ah!
Jesus!
Sorry!
Ah, you!
Dang it!
Ah, that's so mean!
Safe.
Ah!
My durability.
Oh.
Ah!
And there's nothing in here.
You're so rude.
I knew it was coming.
I knew it was.
Oh, I
see him.
I see him.
You guys see him up there?
Oh, where'd he go?
Wait, am I crazy or did he just blip out of existence?
Wait.
Oh?
Wait...
He was just there.
Wait, what happened to him?
I'm not losing it.
I promise.
I'm so angry that I took damage.
I'm so mad.
But now...
Just 40.
I could give up one Higashi, maybe.
More stamina!
More stamina.
Let's go!
You now have more stamina.
Yes.
Yes, I do.
Thank you, I may have missed my earlier super chat.
I'm sorry!
Request a happy birthday!
Oh, Noah!
I'm so sorry!
Happy birthday!
Hey!
Happy, happy birthday!
I'm so sorry!
I missed it.
Okay.
My knife is still at the good...
Do I have toolkit?
I have one.
Okay.
We'll keep the knife on us then.
I think he actually left.
Alright, I know I can run, but I'm nervous.
Oh, I hear him again.
That's the thing about this game.
Because I know I can run.
But I'm nervous about it.
Especially when I have things like this running around.
They run at me.
Okay, so he's like a scripted guy.
What are you eating there?
Surely not.
Some treats that were for me.
Is that an axe?
It's not the easiest weapon to yield due to how heavy it is, but it is reliable.
What should I get?
What should I get rid of?
What was he eating here?
I don't know.
I feel like it's maybe similar to the sledgehammer.
Drop the pipe, really?
Pipe is basic.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
It's a little slow.
Um...
Okay!
Cool.
Um...
Does this circle...
Wait, so... Sorry, I'm just getting my bearings.
What is up here?
It's slow, slow, yeah.
What is up here that I will regret going to see?
We're exploring a tad.
Just a smidge of...
I guess I could try out the axe on her.
Okay.
I think I can maybe...
Wait, hold on.
I need to check something in the tutorial real quick.
Combat.
Hold on.
When I do...
I can't remember when I do the charge attack if it's RB or RT.
Focus.
Okay, it's RB.
Okay.
Oh, I can't move.
Oh, that's right.
I do, if it's a heavy weapon.
Oh, shoot.
Pink bunny girl running at you with an axe is an aesthetic.
Ah.
I see that right there.
Is it worth it?
And, oh, there's something right there.
Oh.
You.
Who?
Where?
Where will you come from?
Strange note.
To whoever finds this, please immediately.
There's here.
I beg you.
Help.
No.
No way.
Who?
Where?
Leave me alone.
I'm tired.
Okay.
So now...
We just keep going.
I'm gonna go save.
One minute, guys.
I'm being a baby.
I'm so sorry.
Danik, welcome back.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Am I being a baby?
I don't care.
Yeah.
Whatever.
I don't care.
I'm being a baby.
Protect the baby.
Alrighty.
Okay.
Now I walk.
Wait, is this the right way?
Yeah.
It does go around.
What's on the other side?
What's over here?
I think I regret being curious.
Nothing!
Stingy.
Stingy game.
Bibby Quarry, thank you so much for the five gift, thank you!
What is that?
That's a...
Oh.
Yeah.
Wait, there's two of them.
Oh, no.
Oh, jeez.
Oh geez, oh geez, she's fast, she's fast.
Oh geez, oh geez, oh geez.
Oh gosh, I'm too slow with this thing.
Get her!
Get her butt!
Yeah.
Oh, I'm really slow though.
Trying to decide.
Only three hits, yeah.
Hold on, I'm checking the map.
I'm thinking...
I'm...
See, there's like this little, that little like area to the left, but I think I might just want to run past this dude.
But I'm checking over here if there's anything.
Yes.
Good stuff.
Can I run past you?
Please, let me...
Wait, what's that?
Oh, wait, oh!
Oh!
Okay, just kidding.
I'm running.
Oh, that was inside the house!
Wait, but I kind of want to see what's in there.
I accidentally discovered the way.
He's just going all by himself.
What if there's...
Well, okay, just kidding.
Ah, anyway.
yeah later alligator we ignore him we ignore that guy we don't care about him
okay my game just saved so I feel a little bit better
okay wow this area is like all we are like two feet away from the school I feel like we're so far from his house.
You're walking in the woods.
There's no one around and your phone is dead.
Out of the corner of your eye you spot her.
Okay, I hear things from literally both sides.
Oh, whoops, that's not what I meant to do.
There we go.
That's what I meant to do.
I think for whatever is around here, we... I can't see where it is, though.
I might want...
Uh, my knife instead.
Where Ramin?
Oh, he's up in the tree!
Oh my god.
Quit monkeying around up there.
roads.
Well, what's in the middle here?
Surely this is probably some kind of puzzle of the sorts.
Oh, nothing?
Okay.
Just, uh...
Just another way around.
Is this way blocked or something?
Am I crazy?
No?
Okay.
Oh, to the...
That little ghosty's room, son.
Just warning, you guys.
Okay, I'm just going around.
What's in here?
Quidzu.
Um.
Erm.
There we go.
That actually works out.
This is still in the tree.
Oh, I see her.
Oh!
You see him!
Oh, shoot.
Huh.
What's he standing there for?
Oh.
Are you scared of the stairs?
You are pretty hefty.
You might lose your balance.
You don't have really, like, a good...
you know.
What's he doing there?
Sorry, I'm just trying to...
Okay, so there is like a tiny shrine ish, maybe?
Hold on, let's go around.
Sorry.
I'm stalling 100%.
And you can call me out on it.
Wait.
Oh, no, what's down here?
Oh, I almost missed this.
My throat is a little sore.
today from yesterday sorry guys so sorry is that the audit auditory clue that something will attack me after this if I grab whatever's in here oh a toolkit that's huge runs away um
What was I doing?
Oh, the other side.
I ran past the bridge.
This is times like these where I wish I had a gun.
Come on, Japan.
Salvi, thank you so much for the redirect.
Thank you.
Welcome in.
Welcome.
Oh, geez.
Jeez, always.
Yeah, I hear you.
you i hear you up there
ew he's just squirting thank you so much for the gift dude thank you thank you papers thank you i guess you have to thank you if you're not going to archery right my girl i just don't like when they jump up at me you know okay wait so there is a staircase going down I kind of want to...
I don't like when they jump up at me.
He's with.
He's just chilling there.
I think he really doesn't like the stairs.
And we have no idea what's beyond there.
I can't... I can't tell.
I could run past this lady.
Thank you, thank you!
I have thank you!
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Ah, I hate this.
there she is okay oh oh both of them get aggroed at the same time okay come come come come oops ouch oh gosh she hits they hit hard they hit really really hard
okay so you can't come down the stairs or oh okay I'm just gonna do this real quick okay
so this is not the way to go obviously but there's water um does water sell for more than ramanay he represents shu's hatred of walking up the stairs after school so true eat the yokan oh that's true we could just do that yeah yeah there we go Well, good thinking,
gang.
It's just squirrels.
Oh my gosh!
I took a walk!
I took a walk yesterday and I saw a possum.
I was like, whoa!
There's a possum.
Oh, he left.
Not really, but like, kind of.
Alright, I think I'm just gonna...
I have to run past him.
No, it was that night when I saw him.
I thought it was a squirrel going up a tree.
Wait, where am I?
Hold on.
Oh, I just went the wrong way.
Okay, but we're picking this up.
I thought it was a squirrel and I was like, that's a really big squirrel.
But it was a possum.
Research notes on Hakko Kusou.
I have learned from reading exotic or herbology that Kakura Makakura is made by grinding up the seeds of Hakko Kusou, an extraordinarily rare herb.
Hakko Kusou is notoriously difficult to cultivate as it requires a very specific environment in which to grow.
Rarely found in the wild.
This precious medicinal herb is so prized.
it has earned itself the title of the flower of the gods according to folklore the herb can give one the ability to converse with gods visit visit their lands what does that mean we're visiting the gods lands and even awaken dormant powers with the manifold divine experience this herb is rumored to provide it it is no surprise that numerous legends talk of kings journeying to find it under the belief it holds the key to immortality when ground its seeds are said to smell of peaches i think this is a drug
okay he's just doing his own thing did i get everything over here yeah okay we're gonna run Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
And look at the map.
This place is huge!
Wait, so I can go under the bridge.
What?
Or I could go this way.
I'm just looking for a save point, actually.
Wait, so if I go this way...
What?
This place is humongous.
Anyway...
The bad music is back.
Uh, I think?
Actually, I can't tell.
I'm just walking.
I'm walking here!
Uh...
So I see the tree down here.
There's a tree here.
That we'd be doing a little bit of hiking.
so this is blocked we'll just make it marked on the map there we go okay so we have to go to the north well isn't that good because shoes is all the way up there shoes house is north so it makes sense that we need to go up wait does this open oh my
god where oh my god my god dang it oh shoot i tried to dodge but i'm stuck oh my god this is so bad
alja stop please i'm i'm so dead i'm so dead because of this damn weapon oh my god no i got the sledgehammer
i have to do all of that all over again Oh my god!
Oh!
There he is up in the tree.
Look at the little monkey.
Get out of here.
Oh man!
Okay, well we know what's in this area at least.
Oh, that sucks though.
Stinky.
Stinky situation.
That was, that was like the worst spot to be trapped in.
Toolkit.
Like, with, with the weapon I had.
I forgot about how badly the game, um...
Was there anything over there?
I don't think so.
I don't remember.
but uh how badly the weapons like get get stuck
yeah we weren't so far it was mostly me exploring exploring so it could be worse what was down there i don't remember
look on oh wait come come come and Oh my god!
Again!
Suck!
I got her first.
And we're... Oh, I got her?
Nice, okay.
That was so bad.
Long weapons are evil.
Okay, it was you.
Oh, oops, wrong button, sorry.
Divine water.
Oh, that's right.
I was gonna eat the yokan.
one i mean honestly i can have both but whatever oh yeah the game is evil a little bit sometimes oh
he's not afraid of the stairs oh yes he is but
um what you doing there bud i'm running i'm running i'm running i'm running i'm running
Seriously?
I don't know if I need to like read this again to have something activate.
Okay, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
The thing that I opened up seems to be just a shortcut around.
So do I need to go back there and open it?
Like the save point is so far, there should be enough.
one like what I'm gonna do though is I'm still going to do this and then yeah I just spawn the enemies screw you screw you we're just gonna keep on walking and hope for another save point because it's so far let's
go this way
Pantages!
Uh, what I will do is...
You.
Uh, delicious.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
I don't want to deal.
So...
True!
Yeah!
Kill her!
Oh, she's dead.
Go away.
Alright.
Where did she come from?
Mysterious.
That guy is still over there.
That's him.
Okay.
Where is a save point?
Am I missing it?
Am I blind?
Wait.
Nope.
That's a map.
And she came from the trees.
Oh, greatly decreases the amount of stamina consumed when sprinting in fights.
It's close.
We're good.
Oh, I see you.
I see you right there.
I finally...
Did we?
Oh, it saved!
Okay, well, the game saved for me, so I don't feel so bad.
Oh, what is this?
I locked our sanctuary to protect it, but don't you worry, because I have the key.
I'll be waiting for you at the mountain refuge.
I won't let anyone or anything hurt you anymore.
I'll protect you until the end of time itself.
I'll stay by your side until death do us part.
Are we not concerned about them right like if they were the ones who were writing these notes Are we not concerned about the tone of them at all or are we just gonna ignore that Oh we got a map what whoa okay cool We're just gonna be like part okay it's so normal it's fine because currently i don't think it's them writing it obviously but it's just kind of funny that she's just like oh they wrote this they must be at the shed okay cool like it's just just normal for her no our yokan i wish where is the save point so i can offer something Oh,
there's two of them?
Why?
I guess I could run past, but why?
Well, the game did just save.
Oh, what's happening here?
Oh.
Oh!
They didn't wake up!
And I just ran into this guy.
Wait, this is like...
This also feels like a boss fight.
This...
Oh, another one?
Why?
And I can't lock onto them, which means they'll wake up later.
When I'm running home.
When I'm running away from this area.
Oh my gosh, another one!
there's gonna be a bajillion of these guys around oh my gosh I like how the tree has faces the view's great isn't it I've always wanted to see it with you you're probably alright if you made it this far but just to be sure you're not being followed by anyone right this is our own private sanctuary we don't need anyone else sorry my headphones are starting to it's only my right ear that my
earbuds bother only my right ear you're my best view yeah the new ones yeah i ended up getting uh the iems because i'll be honest i've had my old headphones like the over the ear ones for a really long time.
Maybe not a really long time, but they've started to get kind of like gross.
Like some days, some days I'll have makeup on and I'll put them on.
And like the makeup is still kind of still on them.
And I can't wash them.
So they're kind of gross.
And I was like, I don't really want to use them anymore.
So
So...
Yeah.
Gotta clean the padding.
But how?
I can't take them off.
I don't dislike these IEMs right now so far.
It's just my right ear.
My left ear is totally fine.
My right ear is like, oh my gosh, I had coffee and my hands can't stop shaking.
No, you can't replace the pads on these.
I have tried.
You can't, you cannot.
Unless there's a secret that I don't know about.
But like, I don't want to tear them off and break them.
At the moment, it feels that way.
I don't remember what.
I just only know that they're Razor headphones.
But I don't know which ones they are.
Specifically.
Okay.
No one is following us, right?
Why are there so many?
Wow!
We're like right next to her.
The booty crack.
Wow.
What's over here?
More note?
Oh, just capsules.
There's so many.
This feels like a boss.
Well-defined booty.
Booty crack.
Just making sure I'm not missing anything.
This is so freaking me.
If they all come to live, it's over.
If they all wake up, I will just...
I'll just...
Look, she's even holding a dive!
I'm just asleep.
Don't mind me.
Don't even try.
Uh-oh, my durability though.
I got you.
What is this?
Oh, another Emma.
Save point.
I'm in Tokyo this weekend.
Any suggestions?
Suggestions for fun things to do.
Hold on.
Give me one second to not have so much anxiety.
Oh, we made it.
We made it.
Oh, gosh, getting to a safe point feels so good.
Okay, let's get rid of the ramen in the divine water.
Yeah, that should be good.
Oh, feels so good.
This looks like it's going to break open, no?
Oh, the gate key.
Things to do in Tokyo this weekend.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know what's going on this weekend.
I don't know.
Why is my mind drawing a blank?
Yeah, always visit maid cafes.
Halloween?
For Halloween, you probably would want to go to like Ikebukuro, I think.
planetaria wait i think i've been there before
wait let me check i might have to get some food soon i'm starting to get so shaky
yeah i have been here the conica planetaria it's really nice yeah i remember i went and uh the guy i went because the narration was by um oh my god oh my gosh why my brain wants to say yonezu kenchi and it's absolutely completely wrong um uh uh k uh tuda kenjiro was the voiceover and his voice is like so so um nice so that's why i wanted to go listen because he has like the butteriest voice ever and there was a part at the end when like it got really quiet and even the music stopped and everything was over and you it's like complete silence in the room and then suddenly you hear a guy go
yeah he's got like the sexiest voice ever
it was so quiet it was quiet like you didn't hear this guy the entire time and then as soon as the room just was like matt it was like maybe like a minute away from the program ending as soon as as soon as it was like the absolute silent in the room just anyway yeah um that would be fun you could always do that uh i don't know why my mind is drawing such a blank on like things to do in I think the there's like I don't know just just go have fun I always recommend Enoshima though I love Enoshima it's a little out of Tokyo though have I recommended team labs I've been to a couple of the team labs there's one in Ginza I don't recommend that one because i feel it's it's there's a bunch of goldfish not sorry i i lisped because i almost bit my tongue there's there's a bunch of fish but like they're in there i don't think the conditions they have them in is very nice so if you go to team labs there's one is it odaiba does is it i think it's odaiba that one's not so bad So,
uh, Odaiba, yeah.
Yeah, the one, the team labs in Odaiba, I recommend.
I don't recommend the one in Ginza because of the fish.
It makes me sad.
They're like very overcrowded and in very small tanks.
And I'm like, this just makes me so sad.
Yeah.
Anyway.
You've come such a long way, you're doing so well.
You don't need to worry about your silly old mundane world anymore.
We'll break free from all of that here.
Welcome to our sanctuary.
The others are overjoyed to have you as a new addition.
I didn't know that this was the gate key, so now I'm scared.
Where are we?
So I go inside here?
Oh my gosh!
Ah!
Whoa!
I got a crowbar!
Um, let's get rid of the sledgehammer.
Ugh!
Sorry.
Ew, he's licking me!
Oh, gross.
Uh, I can't see anything.
The camera angle is terrible.
Oh my gosh.
Ouchy, ouch.
Wait, I'm trying to use...
Oh, there it is.
Is he dead?
Oh, wow.
Wait, this thing is awesome.
Well, that was not great.
Let's look around a little bit before I go inside.
Let's just...
Nothing, maybe.
Hopefully nothing.
Oh!
Shriveled...
Abura Aagi.
I will go donate that.
What was that?
I'm running.
Actually, because I kind of took some...
I took some damage there.
Wow, 500!
Nice.
Let's go.
Let's go!
I could draw some Wait, I'm so close to being able to Wait, no, I can upgrade my health You guys think I should I've upgraded everything else Or I feel like my stamina might be Good enough At this point to be able to just upgrade my health So that Yeah Health or gotcha Next time we'll gotcha That didn't feel like I feel like I feel like that should have been bigger.
Wait.
I'm just seeing what's here.
Oh, we're on the other side of the tree.
Oh.
And then...
Is there anything here?
I'm not gonna do that.
Because I'm not gonna... I'm not...
Fool me once.
Shame on me.
I mean, wait.
Fool!
Wait.
Fool me once.
Shame on you.
Full of me twice.
Double.
What do you mean I can't open it?
Why?
Open the gate.
Oh, this gate!
Oh!
Oh.
Wait, so I have to go...
Wait, so wait.
Oh, I do have to go all the way back around.
Oh my golly.
Just kidding.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Dang it.
Oh, no.
This takes me...
Okay.
I'm just...
So if I move this and then I go to the...
Left.
And then it takes me back to the ponds.
And then...
Oh my gosh.
This is...
Far.
No?
Am I reading this correctly?
My game just saved.
Oh, why?
Wait, oh.
Okay.
Okay, I'm just determining the path that I want to take.
Oh wait, so I maybe should have opened that thing that the little that the guy dropped down before.
It would have been a shortcut.
Ah, okay.
Ah, it would have, ah, the shed right there in the middle.
I should have opened that up earlier.
Okay, all right.
I'm going to go to the right.
I'm gonna go around, circle, go up.
Wait, uh, wait, this way.
Wait, sorry.
From here, um, I need to go down across the bridge.
Okay.
What do I think?
Wait, what was that?
I think that.
I think here.
Wait, uh, what do I get?
Okay, we go to the right oh geez okay to the right across the bridge okay yeah i think oh geez ah what i was i was pressing b you guys i was like spamming b this is so messed up go ran please okay hold on and then I go to the left here.
And we're just gonna lock the gate on them?
Oh, that worked.
Investigate the area.
So true.
So true, girlie.
Just a QK.
QK shins.
Why?
I didn't get too investing in the area!
Ah!
Sorry.
This is not good.
Let's run.
Run.
It's so beautiful though.
Oh, sorry.
The game is really like, hey, you will speed run this part.
Go, please!
into a cutscene!
Yippee!
What shrine are we at?
Cool!
I was about to...
I was literally opening the map when I fell into the cutscene.
Yay, we made it!
If I go back, what would happen?
Let's not test it.
Maybe.
Let's go save, and then we'll test it.
Nah, the Tori saved us.
Now we'll go test it.
Nothing's here!
Wait, really?
Nothing here?
Nothing.
here um okay i don't want to go too far back i want to just progress so do we go to shu's house but what's up here
this place is uh
is that why it's so run down yeah wait have you
She's your friend and you've never been here before?
What is that over there?
It looks like a ghost wearing a sheet.
Yeah, yeah, Shu's house can wait.
I'm gonna steal from this shrine first.
We're gonna go offer this.
And then we're gonna get some more money.
Then we're gonna do gotcha.
Do you think they're gonna be surprised when I show up?
Be like, hee hee!
I'm here!
We'll offer one hikashi.
What's my health looking like?
Yeah, it's okay.
I like how the bunny ears twitch.
They're so cute.
Guys, I've been putting a lot of money.
lot of thought into my next outfit, what I want.
I think I've talked about this.
I've kind of talked about this before, but because of like Ayami Mama's schedule and Celia's schedule, I'm not gonna be getting a lot of outfits, you know.
So I have to, I have to really like, really want what I want next, you know what I mean?
And I can't decide.
I've been going back and forth between, like, three different ideas.
I'm just like...
Yeah, I have to really make them count.
Yeah.
It's tough.
Let's see.
Okay, we'll go to Shoe's house now.
Even though there's more to explore at the shrine.
I feel like it won't be the last time we go there, right?
Taken in the atmosphere.
Okay.
So yeah, I don't know yet.
Why do even the zombies have pretty pine too?
What?
What's this?
Nothing.
I might have to make some food soon.
The coffee I got today was like making me...
I think it was like super.
Yeah, Shoe's house, right?
Is this not Shoe's house?
Wait, how is this not marked off yet, though?
I can't go through here.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Uh-oh.
It's kind of red here.
What is this music?
So scary.
Um, I don't want to go inside.
We'll look around real quick.
Oh, the music is...
They're really creepy.
How silent hill.
How silent.
Uh oh, it's out, it's off sync.
New weapon?
They got any good plants?
Aibo!
It's me!
Was that convincing?
Aibol!
It's me!
Wait!
Oh wait!
Is this not the Silent Hill?
One reference?
Right here?
It's me!
Blarney from Black Mesa!
Yeah!
Oh, we found it!
Cool, cool.
This looks like it will eventually lead to somewhere.
Oh, just kidding.
Is there really nothing around?
Oh, okay.
Aibo?
Aibo, you sure got a lot of medicine in here.
Oh, front doors!
Keys to Shu's house.
Oh, well, good thing we needed to come back here anyway.
Wait, why did they give me so much medicine?
Oh, geez.
The key to Shu's house looks like it's been left here, stained with dust.
dirt from shoes, long days of growing herbs.
Prescription for my partner.
Hinako began complaining of headaches in middle school.
When I tried pinpointing their root cause, things always seemed to come back to stress arising from her poor relationship with her father.
In other words, she is suffering from tension headaches.
I first recommended that she use over-the-counter medicine, but soon she started asking for them more and more often.
I don't like the thought of Hinako developing a reliance on such drugs, so I switched her to traditional Chinese medicine that uses kudzu root and peony, as it should put less strain on her body.
That said, I know the real reason she comes around so often isn't just because she's looking for medicine, but for a place to err her grievances about her father.
As my grandmother always said, you can greatly improve the flow of someone's chi by simply Simply by listening to their troubles and empathizing with them.
Hinako was thrilled with the medicine I gave her and said it worked wonders.
But the truth is that it wasn't the medicine alone.
I want to hear out all her troubles and concerns.
I mean, that's my job as her partner, right?
Okay.
Um.
He doesn't, he seems nice.
He's trying to help.
Honestly, like.
Like, I haven't seen any issues with Shu so far.
Like, it seems nice.
Okay.
Wait.
Can I go in through here?
Oh, it's stuck.
When did it save last?
Sorry, I'm just...
I'm so paranoid.
Oh, okay.
The shrine.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, what about here?
Here we go.
I don't like going inside the houses, though.
But Niaofa makes it less scary.
She is very cute.
Very easy on the eyes.
What a picture to have.
have on here when you first walk in.
I had a feeling.
Oh my god, it's the Yeti!
Oh my god!
Oh dang, her arms are really getting beat up.
Oh no, we're gonna lose our other sleeve at this point.
Oh no!
Back to dream world.
Sasquatch is the... it's the elusive Japanese Sasquatch.
A dangerous path.
For whom do I tread such a treacherous path?
Why are they holding hands?
Excuse me?
Hello?
She didn't look so good.
Did you guys notice that his hair is white and oh my god the doll run hurry there's no going back.
Oh, no His hair is white and the and the foggy monster's hair is white
Oh Creepy
This guy is such a red flag.
He's always he's always ditching us and meet those His hair is white!
He's not a fox, he's a Sasquatch.
The ear wiggles are so good.
My doll is just trying to help us.
Oh, he's down there.
What did it say, reach the first chamber?
There we go.
Oh no, seems a bit like a red flag to me.
What's down here?
Okay.
Can I attack it?
Nope.
We cannot.
Why is he's always shutting doors on us?
He's abandoning us.
Like the guy.
If he loves us so much.
Why do you?
Why do you push me away?
Wait, hold on.
I want to see the other side first real quick.
He's shy.
You think so?
It's really dark.
Okay, I'm scared of the dark.
It's playing hard to get.
Maybe.
Wait, was that him?
I saw something blue.
What we got here?
Bandage?
Family Physicians Log February 10th.
I've received reports that the patients will sometimes make strange sounds, then try to get on all fours and crawl around.
housemates who serve the family for many years whisper amongst themselves speaking of so-called fox possession i have scolded them for spreading such unscientific superstitious superstitious rumors
sorry today i was ordered to keep silent about this matter by the head of the house the family has denied my request to transport them to a hospital I wonder if it is out of fear that talk of the supernatural or tarnish the family's reputation however I do not expect the patients conditions to improve with in-home treatment alone so guys I took one of my headphones out of my right the one in my right ear so hopefully there's nothing that I hear in the right oh my god this room is your fungus way i was about to say hopefully i hear nothing on the right side but uh definitely stuff on the left thank you so much for the breathe that worked thank you thank you
okay actually i feel super paranoid so i'm going to put my headphones back in pain aside i gotta have them both in I guess you have to thank you so much for the gifted teacup thank you so much for the gifted teacup oh there she is
I'm gonna go save
let's just save on this one
did I have anything to offer Eh, well we have none other than we're okay right now.
So stressful.
I know for what reason.
Solemn letter.
Halt the spread of corruption from the mortal world on thy hand and cleanse it to a silver and noble sheen.
Rejoice Hinako and be welcome.
Okay but like this...
This seems a little...
It won't budge.
Wait, what's this?
More higashi.
I will offer you.
Wait.
It's too heavy!
Let's try going this way.
I guess I'm going up to the...
The up here...
The music is getting bad.
Somebody is afoot.
Okay.
I was just checking to make sure it doesn't...
Oh!
I think we found the suspect.
Ah!
I hear like...
Baby.
What's up with the walls?
Okay, we do want to keep trying these though so we can...
Uh...
So that we can cross them out, you know.
Wait, but also...
Oh, they're just kidding.
Okay.
Baby!
Wait, that's the room I need to get into, maybe?
Blue.
We just gotta lead literally every single monster into here.
That's my health, okay.
One moment, sir.
Actually I'll follow you.
It's so formal.
Okay.
What was the whole point of that other area?
I guess you find notes and stuff.
From exploring.
I guess I have to go back eventually.
Oh, come on.
Oh my god, there's two of them.
There's...
Yeah, you're just...
They're just stretching.
They're just like repositioning, you know.
Alright, let's go through here.
I will try to avoid fighting two at once.
Oh gosh.
Ow!
Gosh, he got me first.
Okay, well, it wasn't a permadeath, but...
Beggars can't be choosers.
Is there something probably on that table?
Well, I don't care.
I don't care!
Alright.
We go to the right.
Whoa, wait, do we?
Yes.
It's so pretty though.
This will open.
Oh, it actually did!
Okay, shocking.
This is so awkward.
Okay.
Oh.
Good morning, Miko.
Wow.
Can you speak up?
I can't hear you.
Wait!
That's the fog monster's hand!
Wait, I want to see the Miko.
It's my devil arm.
Can I use the Sasquatch arm as a weapon now?
The bunny ears scare me.
What do you mean?
They're so cute.
Bang, bang, bang.
What's this?
Prepare myself?
What's going on?
Are we about to do another boss fight?
She's gonna yank my arm off.
Wait a second.
Oh my god, wait a second.
Wait a second!
Wait, I think I was totally kidding.
But now I...
Wait, was that like...
Wait, oh my gosh, wait.
They're gonna chop off my arm!
Oh my god.
She is like super chill about this.
And they expect her to do it herself?
The amount of force you would need?
New arm just dropped.
I'm blocking.
I'm literally conveniently censoring part of it.
Yes, her arm.
Thank you.
Alright, now attach the other arm.
Wait, we're becoming a Yeti!
He's like, I like my girls a little furry.
Yep, just pop that on there.
Like, this is so stupid.
Wait, I want to see it in all its glory.
Oh, my God.
They just popped it on there like it was like a figure or something.
know, like a nendroid.
The nendroid of Hinako is gonna go so crazy.
Fits like a glove.
Yeah.
Yeah, she's got that yaoi hand.
Oh.
If you get the yaoi arm in the dreams, you get the yaoi arm in real life.
I mean, not yaoi, sorry, the Yeti.
Yeah, the bunny arms do complete the look, doesn't it?
Oh, the painkillers, thank you.
I wish to become foyeri.
I want to know what the doll says about this.
Oh my god, it looks...
Wait, this is so crazy.
Do I actually get to fight with this arm now?
Oh.
We're back in the game?
Equipment!
Fox arm!
My right arm now replaced with the arm of a fox.
The ferocity of a wild beast rests within.
Hold end.
near enemies who have been rendered inanimate to use soul siphon.
This will prevent enemies from reanimating.
Decimate enemies with razor sharp claws.
Enemies defeated by a focus attack with the fox arm will not reanimate.
Huge.
No!
No, no, no.
Let's get rid of something.
I think I have to get rid of a band Wait, oh no, I have like nothing to get rid of.
I think I have to get rid of a bandage.
Me at age 12 after discovering new grounds.
What does that mean?
I think we'll get rid of a bandage.
Oh, it's just the one.
May I please offer this now?
Wait, so...
Oh my god!
Ah!
Wait, can I even...
I can't even...
I lost...
I lost my other weapons.
I can't even switch.
I'm stuck with this Yeti arm.
Don't call it a fox arm.
I know what this is.
I feel it.
I'm starting to...
I think I'm...
I'm starting to, like, really role play this.
Give me teeth.
What the hell, hound arm?
Not a fox.
Oh, it just saved.
Time to try out my new...
Oh.
Enemies that have been rendered inanimate will reanimate after a period of time.
While using the fox arm, hold A near A.
enemies who have been rendered inanimate to use soul siphon.
This will prevent... Yeah, yeah.
Enemy is killed using the fox arm.
Focus attack will not reanimate.
Oh, jeez.
I'm no longer.
I'm not Hinako anymore.
What's this?
This looks like water, yeah.
The way she's walking, too.
She's really leaning into this this dog.
She's got that...
She's got that dog in her and out her!
Oh, we go back through here!
Wait, now do I, like, tear the walls apart, maybe, you think?
Oh, I wonder.
The suspicious walls.
Ah, okay, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ah, there's so much stuff!
Whoa!
Wait, we...
We can now open things.
Oh, there he goes.
Okay, we're reaching the second ritual chamber.
That guy kind of just...
Oh, geez!
Oh, my God.
Soul Siphon.
I did hear...
Wait, I want to go to the save point real quick.
Which was...
Wait, sorry, this place is tripping me up.
This...
Oh, wait, I can open this.
Because of our very strong arm.
Dreamworld Hineko is just her V Supermodel.
Oh, okay.
I just want to offer this stuff real quick so that we can pick up anything else.
This one.
Should we do some gacha?
I don't have any emma, so honestly, I kind of want to just draw a omamari.
It's been a while since we've done one.
Shame we don't get health or something for the siphon.
I was thinking that, but yeah, having them not respawn is pretty nice.
Oh, whoops.
Save first?
Okay, we're going to save scum.
Save scum, save scum.
It's a good one!
That looks just like us!
Greatly increases stun power when weapon durability is low.
Oh.
Should I try again?
I guess that's fine, but it makes me scared when my durability is low.
Try again.
We'll reload the save.
Gifted, thank you!
We're not gonna have the fox arm forever though, right?
Surely.
It's gonna be a good one!
It's scripted.
Oh my god.
it
the rng is made when your game is made it's seeded and
if i did one more we would have like no faith threatening my friends to repay me 500 yen with my fox army
all right anybody who has the same seed as me tell me what you got Tell me what you got next If it's worth it or not What's this?
Solemn letter Thy lovely silver arm grows strong Thy figure no longer mortal but the divine Unto thy limb has the power of purification been bestowed Grace us now with thy newfound strength
Is this why there's like the memes of him I heard it but I thought it was gonna be
Get out Oh geez
I am gonna eat this though Just a little snack So these walls are strange Okay no Doesn't do anything Uh If I go this way Okay We can lift up this door.
Maybe.
Am I gonna get another...
No!
Am I gonna get another arm?
That will make me able to go through walls.
Um...
Yeah, see, the map even shows that there's something behind here.
You could see it.
Okay.
No, thank you so much for the...
Oh, no, gifted.
Thank you.
I feel like having one arm, like, kind of enhances the chuny.
The chuniness of it all, though.
Is that just me feeling that way?
There's someone around here.
Where?
There's something.
There's something around here.
A hundred percent yes.
I think it's...
Oh!
Hi!
It's this guy.
I think it's because, like, um...
What is it?
It's, like, Chunibyo!
Like, the characters often are, like, at their half power, because, you know, you're nerfed, because you're don't, you're not a full demon.
You only have one arm.
But that makes you even stronger.
Because then, like...
I don't know, there's something about it.
Why don't they obey me now?
Oh my gosh, we're like...
We're stunning them.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I was gonna say, wait.
Wait, he's in a blue room!
I'll still soul siphon you.
Even though this is a blue room and I shouldn't have too.
No,
but.
Inu Yasha?
Yeah, yeah.
Very similar.
Okay, here I come.
Okay.
Let's save.
Awesome.
Telling my kids in my class I'm half Yeti and my Dark Yeti powers are sealed in my right arm.
Same thing!
Kisuke, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
It's the same thing.
Cool.
Is this a boss?
I hear something.
There's no way it's not.
Oh, oh my god.
It's like a boss rush.
Killed.
this thing.
Oh, my gosh.
Dodge!
Nice.
Oh, I need more.
I need to dodge.
There we go.
Ouch, Ouch, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Whoa, my arm went crazy.
Dodge!
Nice.
That's actually kind of easier to do this, because, like,
than before.
I'm getting her both at once.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ripenter!
Oh, shoot.
We got her.
Can I take her soul?
This is my purpose.
Eat them up, eat them up, eat them up, eat them up.
We're so much stronger now.
First aid kit.
Hold on.
Oh, there's it.
Okay.
Let's save real quick.
Neat.
This door won't stop me and my Yeti arm.
This is the point where, like, you know, kind of...
A lot of horror games tend to do this too.
Sorry, I don't mean to just complain all the time about this game.
I am having fun.
And I do like it.
There's just, you know...
I'm very picky with horror sometimes.
I had... I think it's because I had like...
Well, not that I...
I had high hopes and it's not that it's like not meeting them.
It's just that a lot of horror will get into like the ridiculousness where...
It doesn't become scary anymore because it's just so like, what the hell?
You're just like, oh, he's holding my Yeti hand.
Kiel!
Wait, no, no, don't bring me...
No, I want to stay with my Yeti!
Oh, yes!
Okay.
What will I get now?
What body part are we replacing?
Wait, am I getting a Yeti stamp?
A seal of authentic Yeti.
Oh?
Where he wants to brand her!
He's like, I'll just hold you then.
Oh my god, no!
Can you not go?
You're a real Yeti now.
Wait, but my uniform!
You're gonna burn my bra!
No!
Oh my god.
Oh, that's icky.
Oh, that's This poor girl.
Let her sleep.
Do I ever... Oh, good.
Wow, we still haven't returned to the real world.
That's it?
My Yeti well done, please.
I prefer a medium rare Yeti.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my gosh!
She does not look good.
Shinako!
Okay, there she's fine.
She looked like she was about to pass out.
I don't blame...
Oh, wow, this is so bad.
I think I gotta get rid of a first aid kit.
No, you're not smelling her burnt flesh.
You're smelling the incense.
Oops.
So what power did this grant me now?
Foxman?
What's my new found power?
Reach the final ritual chamber.
Which is which way?
The power of infection.
Nobody's gonna treat my wounds!
No, this is actually the real trial.
They're just like, now you gotta lick your wounds like a Yeti.
Okay.
Oh, there's a lot going on in here, isn't there?
Oh, golly!
There is a whole party!
Hello?
Oh.
The beastial form!
The kudzu seal will fill up as you use soul siphon or attack enemies.
Once it's full, you can use LS.
Okay.
I have to press down both to awaken my beastial form.
It's my devil trigger.
Enemies that have been defeated using your beastial form will not reanimate.
While attacking using RBE, you can unleash a devastating attack with RT.
Wait, help?
Holding down the attack for longer will allow you to deal.
even more damage.
While in your awakened form, you can perform a counter using RT.
So long as the counter is possible.
Even if you are already in the middle of an attack, use LSRS while in your bestial form to revert the fox arm to its normal state.
The kudzu seal will deplete while you are awakened.
However, if you revert the fox arm before the seal runs out, then the seal will remain partially filled.
Okay, wait, I don't understand this.
So, attacking, if I'm attacking with RB, then I suddenly, if I just, if I'm like, bam, bam, bam, and then I press RT, I get, okay.
I'll try it.
Oh, here we go!
Oh my
god.
Did I suck everything up?
I guess so.
Wow.
You don't even have an HP.
The game has become insane.
Pull my Yeti trigger.
Okay, wait.
Oh, good.
The game just auto-saved.
Okay, I was gonna go save.
But what's up here?
I don't think I've gone up here, have I?
Bam, bam, bam.
No, wait.
No, we have not.
Okay.
Oh!
We got two.
I'm trapped.
Oh, I can't walk over this.
Wait, I can't walk.
Okay, just kidding.
I was fully prepared.
Let's refill our...
Our Yeti bar.
Give me that soul siphon.
Oh yeah!
The illusion of floor.
I like the way she creeps around.
The Yeti creep.
Oh, shoot.
Well, that's okay.
We don't really need it right now.
Maybe later.
Yeti, Yeti, Yeti.
Here I come!
Yeti you're not!
Oh,
shoot.
I'm going to get rid of the Higashi.
I have so much stamina because I keep...
Yeah, I think I'll get rid of it.
Ah, it felt bad.
It felt bad.
Oops.
That's not what I wanted to do.
No way I just threw away.
my stamina stuff and then more stamina
feels bad
yeah there's no way yeah there's no way
like and the thing is is like I wouldn't my first thought wouldn't have been like oh that's definitely something that would expand my inventory I wouldn't have.
I wouldn't have been like, let me go see what the other thing is.
I guess maybe they're expected to be like, let me see what the other thing is first.
Oh, gosh.
You guys, I can't do these IEMs anymore.
Hold on.
I'm switching my headphones back.
I can't do it.
It hurts.
My headphones are so gross.
Ew.
Ah, ah, wait.
Uh, okay, there we go.
I have to, like, change the monitor on a ton.
Okay.
Stop pulling my Yeti arm.
I think
they probably want me to...
Yeah, they probably...
But I want my thing fuller before I...
Before I, you know...
I'm crawling around like a Yeti.
Maybe.
What's this?
Yo kan!
Um, well, what we're gonna do is...
I'll take that.
Okay.
Oh, it must be full for me to use it!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
That makes sense.
Okay, that's where we came from, but there is a save, so I'm gonna go save real quick.
Let's go find the third ritual.
Oh, and I can...
We can also enthrine some stuff, like the carcass and the comb.
Okay, perfect.
Yeah!
If only I could get an Emma.
I could do more health.
Is she cannibal?
No.
She's not cannibal.
Now we go to...
Maybe here?
says it's open.
Oh!
When did these doors appear?
Hmm?
What is this?
Letter from a woman?
You are... wait, I messed up.
Sorry.
You really are shrouded in mystery.
You understand exactly how I feel, even though we haven't seen each other in years.
Are you simply reading me like a book, or am I feeling exactly what it is you want me to recently i'm starting to think that even i don't know who i am anymore lady you could be my wife um
well all the doors now are open so that's kind of cool i just don't know i guess we're just explore
in two days.
Satana, happy early birthday!
I hear something.
There was this guy in here.
Or...
Uh, somewhere.
Behind here?
Ugh, there's so many sounds everywhere.
Yeah,
take her down.
I'll take that.
Yummy.
Sorry, I didn't mean to yell so loud.
Holy cow.
Oh, yeah.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Please!
Let's get them both at once!
Okay, there we go.
Sheesh!
It's almost full.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I did not mean to yell so loud.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Okay.
It's definitely something here, but we don't know what's yet.
It wasn't that loud, it wasn't.
Compression doing its job.
Oh, I think maybe behind...
Oh, wait.
Oh, no, there they are.
Hello.
I want to open this just to open it.
Open it because I can.
Okay.
Where were you?
Oh, you were behind this door.
My sanity!
Holy cow!
Another one?
Or is it was just dying?
Let's see...
There's this door over here that seems like it wants me to open, but I know I've been down there before.
this.
That was, that's good.
Oh, this one right here.
Again, it got me.
It got me.
It scared me.
Oh, my
thing is full though.
Let's eat Okay I hate when they fall from the ceiling Oh, open Does not use her Yeti arm I've taken notice Which way do I go?
Is it maybe This one?
Because it's showing this is like fully Explored, so maybe I do go here Oh, I think four oh yes i went downstairs oh so we do go to the top left this way wait what's here
using my yedi arm oh what's there oh i'm hungry i want inari sushi
Kroki Slightly restores health after defeating an enemy Not bad Not bad, not bad Housemaid's note Me However the child she carried was unmistakably A descendant of the Tzunekis And their blood lies in wait for tragedy to strike It is only a matter of time before that child exacts their revenge I believe that the next time there is turmoil within the Tzineki family,
that child will make their move.
It was just a...
That baby looks like he's out for revenge.
It's the baby.
Okay, I think I go through here.
Oh, there's a lot here.
Ow!
Let's go sacrifice.
Sorry, I get so lost in here.
Okay, we need to go down this way.
Give Inari-zushi.
And then I'll go grab the comb, give the comb, then grab the yokan.
Order of operations here.
Grab the comb, leave the comb.
Enshrined the comb.
We'll grab the yokai.
I could give the higashi.
But right now, I kind of want to keep it.
Okay.
We go through here?
Did I not go in here before?
I mean, I'm not sure, honestly.
Honestly, I'm not sure.
It feels like I did, but...
not.
Foxman?
Okay.
Still going.
Oh yeah, because I remember that divine water.
I definitely was here 100%.
Oh.
Yeah, I was here.
Oh,
wait, now Now it's showing that I...
Wait, no, I'm down...
Wait, oh, I'm upstairs.
Oh!
Oh...
Um...
Oh, wait!
There's that staircase right in the middle.
It goes...
it seemingly goes down, so let's try that one.
Maybe I don't know if I have done that one yet or not.
So if I go straight...
Easy to get lost in this part.
Yeah, a little bit.
Wait, have I gone through...
I hear somebody.
Thought there might be a note.
Okay.
Uh...
So if I go in here...
Oh!
He's talking from over here, right?
Whoa!
Have I gone this way?
It's still lit up, so...
I'm guessing it's...
Correct.
I feel silly.
I feel silly here.
The map definitely looks like it's down.
That's what I thought, right?
That's why I was like, wait, it's going up.
I'm confused.
Confusion!
Well, okay.
Who do I fight in here?
Defeat the monsters, TM.
Oh!
This isn't like killing him immediately.
Oh wow, I missed!
Oh, he's dead, that's why!
I missed because...
He was already dead.
That was funny.
Wow!
Gosh, she's so strong.
Holy cow.
Afraid of nothing.
Did I even take a hit?
I don't know.
Crazy.
What's this?
Yeah.
There we go!
Invincible in Yeti- Oh, that's right, I can't- My health bar disappears when I'm in Yeti mode.
Yeti trigger.
Why am I safe, Akaku?
At least the bunny ears are still intact.
The bunny ears are pristine.
They are in mint condition.
What Yeti part do I get now?
Yeti feet.
Yeti.
Full Yeti reflection.
Look at yourself.
Don't you look kawaii when you're Usamimi?
What's that?
They're gonna take my eyeballs.
No, not that...
Oh, I thought they were about to take.
off the ears.
I think, wasn't that knife part in the trailer?
I think I remember that.
Oh my god, the blood is just...
No!
Face transplant!
Oh, that's really freaky, actually.
It's so freaky looking.
Oh, I can't see out of those pinholes.
Wait a second.
You gotta cut them bigger.
This made my skin crawl.
Yeah.
Wait, there's gonna clash the fox ears and the bunny ears.
I
have six ears.
Too many ears.
Not enough ears.
I'm all ears.
But she's crashing out.
That's why you beat your contract through it, right?
She looks really cute, though.
It looks really good on her.
Why does he get special glowing eyes?
Her eyes look really weird, though.
The music with the doll is so funny.
She's like, oh, hell no.
My girl turned into a Yeti.
Glowing eyes are another operation.
Maybe.
Oh, wait, we're getting a third eye.
Whoa.
Uh-oh.
We're becoming evil.
Becoming?
Well, I mean...
Whoa.
Wait, the mask matches her uniform!
Yeah, it's cute!
It works, it works!
Dang it.
They keep giving me so much stuff here.
Okay, goodbye Higashi.
Wait.
Look.
Can I come back, actually?
I'm not sure.
I need more Emma.
A kid?
You don't think I'll need it later?
Wait, is it not supposed to turn pink?
Like, is that if you're wearing the uniform?
That's actually so cute, if that's the case.
Get rid of first aid kit.
Okay.
Normally it's white!
Wait, that's so cute!
Wait, that's something special we got to see then.
That's fun.
Trash the yokan.
Oh, true!
Because we have all the bandages.
Or actually I'll trash the arare.
Because well, actually I don't know.
It works better when you use more.
I don't know.
I'll come back.
Where's my health?
We're at full health anyway.
You're only 30?
Okay.
I'll trash the open.
I can't come back?
Okay.
Oh.
Hello.
Well,
now I want to read my Fox arm.
Awakened Fox arm.
Beastia form.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, what have I not read?
Oh.
Mask of the Fox clan.
You are now able to see secrets concealed within the dark shrine using the mask from the fox clan you hold lt to use focus and discover hidden paths and clues at certain locations oh i'm i'm skipping the tutorial what did i miss under equipment though oh just heavy weapons okay which
way did he went this way chase after fox mask i'm chasing
head a little bit of what the so now it's probably going to tell me.
There it is.
You're now able to see secrets.
LT.
Okay.
If you spot a suspicious looking area in the dark shrine, use focus and take a good look around.
Oh, I can't.
What do you see with your Yeti eyes?
No!
Whoa!
Oh, so that's what that was.
Okay, that's where we are now.
My Yeti, I see.
No!
Oh, I like how she does the Yeti walk.
Really big fan.
Just some divine water.
That's it.
No note.
No lore.
Yeti Yeti B!
Sometimes I hear the flames and I think it's a creature.
So it freaks me out a little bit.
Uh, I'll hear it.
Not even an Emma.
I know!
Sucks.
I'm gonna do one more poll.
Even though it's not random.
I'm gonna do another poll.
Here I go.
It's gonna be a good one!
There wasn't Emma at the last ritual to be fair.
That's true, that's true.
But they're giving us all this stuff for faith.
And nothing to use it on, you know?
Three, two, one, hoi!
Oh, three, two, one, hoi!
A mantis.
Slightly restores health after each successful counter.
Yeti eyes.
Oh, whoops.
Yeti eyes tell Yeti lies.
Wait, does it show up on the map now?
I can't tell, actually.
Psycho Mantis.
Oh, it dies.
It's just hard to tell.
Oh, neat.
Are there any other rooms?
I don't think there was anything else that... Did I save?
I don't think I did.
Hold on.
I don't know if there were any other rooms that...
Um...
That I needed to open.
Oh my god.
Oops.
That's not what I meant to do.
Eh.
Psycho Mantis!
Metal Gear Natskashi!
Well...
I think we can just go.
Unless?
Oh, the blue flame is out.
Neat.
Okay, this one wasn't.
But we did hear something.
Oh, wait.
No, I think what we heard behind it was the thing upstairs.
Okay, let's just go.
He's gotta be here, right?
Oh, there he is!
Whoa,
is this a wedding?
Is it a wedding?
Oh my gosh, whoa!
Look at her.
Oh,
I can look around.
Look at all the foxes.
Why was that one lady so cool looking?
My sister.
This doesn't seem so bad.
What's the issue?
Yeah, one of those masks is not like the other at all.
Seems kind of nice.
Wow.
Oh, the spines.
So cool.
Oh, they're fast.
They're quiet.
Why are the guys have half masks and the ladies have full masks?
Remember your name is Shimizu Hinako!
Uh-oh.
That doesn't look so good.
Wait, is that gonna hurt?
Holy!
Wait, this is Rinko?
Oh no, oh no.
She became lover.
Holy cow.
Oh no!
You got my fur.
Say it.
Say it!
Hinako!
Oh shoot, okay.
Wrinkle-like...
Oh, wait!
Wait, I didn't realize I was in beast mode.
Ouch, ouch.
Okay, I tried running.
Ah, dodge, dodge, dodge!
Oh, she...
Oh, oh, my...
Ah, my health!
My health run away!
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot!
Wait, there's like, people coming at me!
Oh my gosh, wait, I need a bandage.
Omoe it all!
Ouch, I'll choke.
Oh shoot, uh, we need to run.
The puppets.
Holy cow!
They scared me!
Oh, they're like little bombs!
Wait, I can't see it.
Oh shoot.
Okay, okay, hold on.
Uh, eat?
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Can I soul-siphon it?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I was pressing the wrong thing.
Oh, I can.
Wait, that's kind of awesome.
Ah!
I kept pressing the wrong thing.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
Wait, please.
Please, bandage.
Okay.
Maybe...
Ah, I need to kill them before...
Oh, I'm gaming?
Okay, uh...
I need to leave you, please!
Okay, I got this...
Oh, that's not where I want to go!
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh, no, no, no!
The worst timing!
Ouchy, ouchy, ouchy, ouchy, ouchy, ouchy
Okay, I'm running again.
And I'm full healing.
Oh shoot, oh gosh, ah!
Oh, I'm getting combo, wapo comboed!
Oh wait, my arm is... my arm is normal, okay.
Pull my...
Trigger.
Oh, we got her!
Oh, DT!
Wait, is she in the cutscene with the giant in your?
I'll be honest.
I could barely pay attention to what they were saying.
So I have no idea.
Damn.
Are we going back to...
...
That's my name!
Don't wear it out!
...
Shimizu.
I...
Hinaiko.
J-a-nai.
What's up?
Hinaiko.
I...
You're Hinaiko, jane-a.
You're Hinaiko.
Wait, she's even saying it too though?
Yes.
I...
Shimizu.
Hina...
Janai.
Janai?
No!
Oh,
they took her last name.
She's just Hinako.
Oh.
Yeah, he's leaving the Shimizu out.
The fox looking at her.
Creepy plucked wings.
Anything for you?
Is it the achievement I got?
Oh, no!
My arm!
The back of the uniform is all messed up still though.
What happens in the game happens in real life.
Yeah, he's calling her just Hinako, but she is trying to be Shimizu Hinako.
Oshimaoshi.
Hi.
Who could be calling at this hour?
Okay, please answer.
It's so loud.
Yes?
Shimizu residence?
Please, please answer the phone.
It's so loud.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, Kai-san?
Oh,
creepy!
It's her sister.
I don't know!
Me too.
Oh,
she doesn't look so good.
What does...
Yeah, something doesn't seem right.
It's just...
Oh, no black hair.
Oh.
No black hair.
Don't worry.
Hi Kiwawa!
I hope you had fun with Pokemon.
I'll be true to the thumbnail.
You can always have a lick, Colonel.
How could you lose her?
Her little bell was clanking away.
Thank you so much for the redirect, Kiwawa!
I almost said Kiara and then I wanted to say Kiwawa, so I said Ki-rarwa.
Make your way down the mountain and head to the Shimizu residence.
Oh, that was freaky!
Let's read our journal.
Rar!
Ki-rarwa!
Hi everybody, we're playing Silent Hill F and...
Oh, it's a little freaky.
Um, I just beat a lava lady.
What?
Wait, hold on.
Is there a cat in here?
Hold on, let me check if there's a cat in my room because my window was open.
I'm freaked out.
What?
How was that possible?
There's no cat in my room.
How is my window like that?
Oh, not the...
Sorry, my window...
It's not the window was open.
It's that, like, the curtains were...
The curtains were open in a way that, like, my cats pushed them aside.
But I had fixed them earlier, and then I looked and they were open.
But I didn't do that.
And there's no cat in here.
My...
My maid cafe is already haunted by me.
The campaign...
Well, if it's a ghost cat, it's fine.
if it's a ghost cat it's fine nothing gets on my nerves more than other people trying to make decisions for me even if what they're saying is right it just rubs me the wrong way i'd rather make a hundred mistakes on my own than follow someone else's commands you know what i kind of i kind of get it you know i'm like kind of stubborn like that too where someone will be like jump vtuber and i'm like i know you're telling me to jump but you're telling me what to do and i to you but that can make for a lonely life oh where one where i refuse to listen to anyone else oh wait i want to become the kind of person who truly listens to what others have to say oh wait oh god wait they're saying that i'm wrong of course it'll still be up to me whom i listen to okay
And that will be someone I can trust, someone who will walk alongside me, hand in hand.
However, making long lists of things I hate is just a way of running away from the real issue I have with my inner self.
I have to step up and face what's inside of me, even if I don't like what I see.
Being able to take my time and carefully think things through before making a decision is what's most important to me.
Oh, I get it, I get it.
Oh, wait, her face changed to show the mask.
Diagonal Vtuber.
Ah!
Junko always told me that the quickest way to happiness is to live the way society expects women to.
Well, if there's a quick way to happiness, then there must be other ways too.
One time when I was little, Junko showed me how to find my way out of a maze in a puzzle book.
There's no doubt that she showed me the quickest solution.
Still, what I felt at that moment was nothing compared to the joy of figuring it out for myself.
Aww.
Wait, does Rinko change at all?
Oh, we didn't see Shu either!
Oh, no!
Shu!
Sakakos makes me the most sad, though.
I love her.
Uh...
Fox Mask.
His portrait hasn't really changed much, though.
He promised me everything I could ever want to be content.
A life full of comfort for as long as I live.
Status that no one could look like down on and most importantly endless love for me for all this i will give him all of me body mind and soul i will even give him what i have fiercely protected my whole life my will to make my own choices from now on i will let him decide everything for me and simply do as he says this is what happiness means to me oh my gosh i don't know if you remember but a few days ago i mentioned I applied for a promotion,
I got good news.
I got an interview for it by day.
So the sky!
Congratulations!
Yo!
Oh my gosh, you'll totally get it.
You'll totally get it.
Whoa, look at it.
We got the Yeti arm.
Wait, we look so cool.
Mom looks same.
Dad looks same.
Nice.
All right, let's see where we're headed to.
the mountain and head to Shimizu residence.
Where was that?
Where do I live?
I am...
Actually, don't we live up here?
Oh my gosh!
Wait a second!
I should be able... I should head up the mountain!
No?
Sounds like we should be doing the opposite.
Yeah, actually, we are...
It's getting dark.
It's getting pretty dark outside.
Oh, wait.
I just went...
Okay.
I was gonna check and see if this way was open, but it turns out it is now.
Very cool.
I missed my Yeti arm.
I miss it very much.
Just got hope for work.
Today's...
Her triggers!
Happy birthday!
I'm happy to...
to be here for another year with you and the wisps.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
So many birthdays today!
Wow!
All right, Shemizu Residence.
But this is going up.
This seems like the corrective defraction, no?
Well, my game is starting to lag a little bit, sorry.
The little fox is so cute.
Um.
What the heck was that?
That don't sound so good.
And I saw that there was a baseball bat, but I don't think we need to switch anything out.
What I have.
I don't like what I heard.
We're back to being vulnerable and I don't like that.
Wait, can I even go around that way?
Hold on, sorry, I'm...
Wait, let's go down.
I want to see what's down there.
I'm not even sure.
It's feeling very silent hill now.
Where did I... I know... Oh, I saw these things in the other world.
In October to November birthday means you were likely a Valentine's Day gift.
Hello, hello!
Oh, yeah, yo, yo.
Oh, I thought she was gonna run up.
My bad.
I thought she was...
I mean, she did run up.
I just miscalculated it.
Sorry.
Oh, use focus.
I said...
The map is like tripping me out because I can't... I'm like...
I'm surprised this isn't going.
Because I can't get my bearings on like the... Oh, okay.
It's more like slanted to the left.
Okay.
I can't go inside here, right?
Okay, thank goodness.
Hello everybody, getting off of work?
And such?
You think there's somebody in there?
That's a creaky house.
This house do be creaking.
Oh, it's actually really big.
Way bigger than I thought.
I'm going to work.
Have a good day of work!
Have a good day of work.
Uh, peels here.
I don't trust it.
Do I need the peels?
I think I'm...
I have seven peels.
Wait, how many pills is the max pills?
I don't know.
I think we're okay.
Ten peels!
Okay, I'll take the peels.
I'm scared for it, though.
I'm ready to dodge.
Okay, good dodge.
I once had 48 pills in my inventory.
No way!
Do I take them too often?
It's starting to get kind of icky around here.
What's that speaker for?
Is that a speaker or satellite?
I'm actually not sure.
Ooh, we're starting to get...
Oh.
My game is really lagging sometimes, huh?
Okay, we can't go through that way, but I can take their stuff.
And I for sure will do that.
Clinical trial.
I began taking this medicine out of desperation.
My first impression was that it smells of peaches and is faintly sweet.
That's the thing we read about earlier, the miracle drug.
After taking it before bed for the past three nights, I had my first lucid dream.
For a whole night, I was able to organize my thoughts in a pleasant darkness.
Sounds like my worst nightmare.
Was this what the tale meant when they said, sorry, I can't read.
Was this what the tales meant when they said the drug allows you to speak with your inner self?
I've heard of taking vitamin B6 makes it easier to remember dreams.
Is that true?
However, I'm sure its effectiveness depends on factors like dosage and body composition.
At any rate, this has been a letdown so far.
Okay.
What are you trying to do?
I think we can just step on it.
A rope.
A part of me thought that was going to strangle me.
Like in half-life.
I was going to...
No way!
What?
We have the...
The titty lady here!
why why why okay we're gonna have to get past her oh my god the who you guys you have to see her I'm not making her up here actually I could show you that's the titty lady.
That's her.
Oh, wait.
A monster that has a large taiko drum inside its mouth.
How cute.
It swings around its large bachi drumstick like arms and strengths the taiko to instill fear and command those bound to it.
It tries to cancel out any noise with its loud voice and banging.
That's how it's always been.
I killed it so fast I didn't even notice.
She's perfect.
beat Sakuko and now we have Rinko a monster that has taken the form of a head priest it sounds just like Rinko swinging around and Onusa stuff used for purification rituals this creature is consumed by the fires of jealousy or the fires that I literally I literally dropped her into lava but you know remains surrounded by babbling puppets there's no way Rinko is a monster like this But this is her,
without a doubt.
If I'm looking...
Okay, I'm looking at the monster.
Sorry.
I don't know why the map is suddenly, like, tripping me up.
Okay, I need to go over that way.
But what's over this way?
You know?
It's fine.
I'll just run.
Oh, can I?
Defeat the monsters!
Wait, I can't run!
Okay.
Well, um, no way.
No stinking way.
Uh, because that's where I need to...
That, I think, is... Hold on, sorry.
Okay, yeah.
Oh, here she comes.
Oh, she's gross.
Oh,
I miss my arm.
Ouch, out, out, out.
Oh, she's burning.
I'm birthing another one!
Which is...
Oh, there's two of them!
Oh, she's birthing another one!
Oh my gosh, I'm out of stamina.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I got it.
Come here, lady.
Oh, no.
This one.
Let's kill it.
Oh, it exploded!
Okay.
Oh, gosh, ouch.
Oh, stop it.
Stop birthing.
I thought I killed her, but I...
Oh, get out of...
Oh, I have no stamina.
I have no stamina.
Wait, I'm...
Wait, it keeps, like, trapping me.
That's so weird.
Okay.
please stop birth oh my gosh okay hold on I'll take another one more pills okay so the blue ones just explode oh geez no No!
Oh,
that sucks.
Oh, come on, I pressed B, but not fast enough, I think.
No, my crowbar!
I'm trying not to get exploded.
It got stuck on its own thing.
Oh man, my crowbar.
Ah!
Microbar!
So lucky!
What are you showing me now?
A hideous monster covered in countless skin cysts.
He spawns monster after monster from its dreadful smelling clumps of flesh it drops.
Filthy, foul, and repulsive.
The wonders of birth do not apply to this.
Everyone agrees.
All right.
Heading back home.
Okay.
It did auto-save, but I could use another save port.
Another radio.
Death, death, death.
I don't feel like going over there.
This does feel like the beginning of the game, sort of when we were going through like the area where we live.
in.
Except just more goofy.
This is something up here.
Something.
Perhaps.
Ah!
Why?
Yeah, pick her out.
Oops.
Is there anything over here then?
There better be.
For me to get jump attacked?
Something in the...
There's got it...
There's something.
Oh, there is!
Oh, perfect dodges become easier to perform.
Interesting.
Right now, the omamari I have right now is for my stamina.
Oh, change it to the one that heals you.
after...
I guess we could.
Oh, I have the hawk, too.
I forgot.
What was it, Mantis?
No.
Crow?
I guess... Wait, what's my health at?
Yeah, actually it might be good to have it like that, huh?
What did I say?
Where are my going.
This seems suspicious.
Oh,
okay.
Oh, I said Hawk.
Space, space, space, space, space, space, space, space, space.
Two.
Uh.
Yeah.
Sorry, I'm getting mixed up a little.
Ew!
Aw, you!
Okay, so, oh, that way is not possible and it shows on the map.
Um, hi!
Oh!
Also, I see something over there, so I think I'm just gonna book it.
Ah!
Are you kidding me?
I don't know if I'm going the right way or not.
I am?
I don't know.
I hear something behind me though.
I just realized...
I just realized that I went to...
Shimiko...
Wait, what's her name?
Not Shimiko.
What's her...
Sakuko, sorry, my brain.
Wait to Sakuko's family shrine, but I didn't go all the way up because I thought I'd be able to go back.
Yeah, I'm thinking I combined Shimizu and Sakuko together.
What do I say?
I heard this water is specifically for washing and cleansing old dirty things.
Strict mother's letter.
Good morning, my handsome boy.
You are different from those delinquents who run around town.
You have noble blood running through your veins.
Of course, every child must play in order to grow.
I simply ask that you choose wisely who you play with.
You must think of me as awfully overbearing, but please respect my wishes while you are still young.
For when you are a grown-up, you will be free to do as you please.
Okay.
Is that about Shul, maybe?
Do I need to bring something here to wash it?
The shrine is a new game plus thing.
Oh, okay, perfect then.
Alright, wait.
I just go down and straight.
Ignore.
Ignore the footsteps behind you!
Down and to my left?
Actually, can I go this way?
No.
Okay.
We gotta go this way?
What footsteps?
Yeah, don't...
worry about it.
Yeah!
Oh yeah!
I can still hear it, it's creeping.
Ah!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god!
Please!
Oh!
He got me before I could!
Oh, no, I didn't mean to do another one!
Dodge, dodge, please.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ah!
I'm stuck in here!
This is so bad!
Oh my gosh.
I can't with this guy.
Ah!
I thought that was the end for me.
I really thought that was the end.
Sheesh!
I don't know where it last saved either.
Worst enemy is the camera.
It can be!
I could have just run, but...
Into the goop.
Good job, though.
Thank you.
It was close.
It was very close.
All right, from here we go to the right.
But what's over this way?
My curiosity is...
Oh, okay, this way is where it's blocked off.
I don't see anything?
Okay.
We're back in town!
Ish?
Okay.
All we have to do is go all the way up the map.
Back home.
I like how these hydrangea have made it through the...
Yeah.
There's like only this area that is still shrouded in mystery.
I guess a little...
Oh, actually no, maybe not.
We've like walked so...
Look at all of this.
Look at this map that we've covered.
This area, too.
I like how there's tadpoles, question mark.
Okay.
We've walked, like, so much of this place, though.
Crazy.
Oh, it's nasty.
Okay.
Of course, we can't go the direction that would be easiest for us.
Of course not.
What's my health?
Okay.
Could be worse.
Taking it slow and steady.
Okay, yeah.
Sorry that I'm constantly checking the map.
I do get a little lost easily sometimes.
Bandage.
Uh-oh.
Who are we about to fight?
They just gave us pills and a bandage!
The game is not so kind!
Shinako needs to invest in a car.
She's in middle school.
She needs to invest in a bike.
That's for sure.
We're going through the creepy playground.
Which looks like...
It's scarily untouched.
Which means something's going to happen in here.
It's pristine.
Why?
Oh, where is the save spot?
Please!
Okay.
We're zigzagging through town.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
What did he get attacked by?
A little...
What is he getting attacked by?
What is that?
A cat?
A fox.
It's gonna get rabies.
That's why.
I...
Oh.
It's 5 p.m.
What's updated?
Oh, maybe Inari-sama?
Oh, the park.
Oh, wait.
There's a couple of new entries.
Episugaoka is mostly composed of Inari-sama believers.
There are statues of Inari-sama all over town.
My elderly neighbors treat them with great respect and worship them.
Inari-sama, also referred to as O Inari-sama, is a goddess that puts old, unusable tools to rest.
They are known for their offerings, preference of aburaage tofu pierced.
Wait, aburaage tofu pierced through with an old needle.
It seems like other towns don't have these customs, though.
I'm guessing they might be something special we only do for Inaresama here in Ebisugaoka.
Oh, she graduated middle school.
Oh, okay.
My doll!
I knew it.
exactly like the one I thought I had gotten rid of that day.
I'm sure it hates me for throwing it away and abandoning it.
When all of this is over, I'll ask my mom for a way to put it to rest.
Aww.
I heard once that there was a shrine in shambles near Shu's house, but I never knew it was here.
Shu told me back then that there's treasure at the roots of the divine tree or something.
Sakako once told me that this place is where real Sennen-Sugi shrine is.
Wait, so in New Game Plus, stuff at the tree i think this park i used to play at a lot when i was little i feel like all my memories of fun times and hard places took hard wait fun times and hard times my my hard places fun times and hard times took place here you can if you do a puzzle oh cool playing house with girls and playing dodgeball with boys but kids will tell you that it's weird for girls to play with boys they told me they wouldn't let me play because i hung out with the boys i remember that moment of rejection and denial crystal clear in my head why do showa kids try so hard to keep boys and girls so clearly separated feels like such an awful thing to be a part of oh is it truly such an awful thing to be part of both groups i was a tomboy and i do remember um girls not caring
Yeah, they really didn't care so much.
What's this?
The lights flickering are just creeping me out.
I should have grown a Yeti arm, I wish.
I think I heard something else too, so...
What is a tomboy?
I think I'm pretty girly now.
Maybe.
I think I hear something like growling over there.
Oh, oh yes.
100% I do.
Okay, it's one of those.
So I might be able to run past.
Sorry, I'm just getting my bearings.
If I run and then go to the right.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
You're not sneaking up.
Come on me!
I won't let you!
Took care of her?
Real fast?
I said no ma'am?
But I'm going to use a toolkit.
Nice.
And I'm gonna...
Just a little snack.
Alright.
I do wonder if there's anything over there, but I don't really feel like...
Oh no!
Squishy!
No!
If I could find a save point, so I could offer this...
Like, where could one be?
What's in here?
Where's your motivation?
Oh, is this just a house?
Wait.
What is this?
Strict mother's letter.
Good morning, my handsome boy.
I know it's a little sudden, but we shall be moving tomorrow.
I've already notified your teacher.
So just make sure to say goodbye to all your friends.
I shall tell you everything at home.
That looks like a box I should be able to open, no?
Oh, wait.
That's fine.
Oops.
Oh, well, I killed it, so it's okay.
I smushed it.
Wait!
My handsome boy!
Even if you find yourself poor of pockets, you must never let yourself become poor of heart.
inherited your father's noble blood you must study hard and learn to be a gentleman do not think of yourself as a little boy for you are simply a tiny adult waiting to grow why is she sending her kid these letters there will come a day when your father shall require help require your help mark my words that's so funny it's kind of sweet though at the same time Yes,
ma'am.
Ina Rizushi.
Hope everything's going good.
What I want to do is check over here.
Thank you.
Grab some things that I couldn't grab before.
And then I might call it.
I went...
I've been wanting the winter to come because my room gets so hot with like how my PC is so I've just been it's been like I don't know recently it's been harder for me to deal with it so I'm just like please winter I'm ready for you oh my gosh wait I believe Kiara raided me,
and right now I'm wearing a Kiara t-shirt.
Wow, how lucky.
It's like it was fate.
I just remember.
I looked down and saw orange.
I was like, wait a second.
I'm wearing a Kiara t-shirt.
It was meant to be.
It was, it was.
Oh my gosh, look at my playtime.
hours almost on the dot.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I was wearing orange.
You glad you chose that shirt today.
I know.
She rated me.
Yeah.
I'm wearing it.
I'm wearing it's the Omocat.
Collab t-shirt.
So cute.
part of me wants to continue but part of me is like hungry i am still enjoying it don't get me wrong especially we became like kind of overpowered at a second i feel like i've gotten a little bit better at the game which makes me less hesitant of playing as well how hungry go eat girl yeah i'm gonna eat you have one big dungeon left it's over.
Really?
Oh, so maybe next time we could beat the game?
What will you eat?
I got pizza waiting for me.
Yeah, I feel like I've gotten better.
I think it's because I have less fear.
Sounds so funny.
I'm fearless.
No, it's because I think I've grown more accustomed to like their attack types and everything.
But I'm getting hungry.
and i feel we did quite a bit so no no pineapple this time just a regular actually i think it has some spanish on it some spanish yummy it's not that scary after a while yeah exactly but it does feel like we are close to the end i guess maybe we have to fight shu since we fought and uh and uh ninkle everyone calls her Kiwaba I spent months thinking her name was Kiara I said not Kiara
Owl's pizza palace is the best pizza in all of London oh my gosh Kalmo you don't know how much I quote that honestly I am constantly being like, I gotta get some pizza from Owl's Pizza Palace.
Um, so I guess we will beat the game next time.
Exciting, exciting, exciting.
Uh, I feel like I could keep, well, okay, part of me, if I... Okay, sorry, my brain is going too fast.
I'm hungry, but you know, I could, like, eat a slice of pizza and be fine to keep going, but the biggest I'm having right now is I have a I have a caffeine headache from this coffee thanks for the fun stream thank you fake name thank you thank you no I say pizza pizza I say it all the time ah so if it weren't for that I think I'd be fine to keep going but we'll just call it here and we'll beat it next week next week baby yeah it's good time to stop.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cool.
When are you gonna play Harvest?
Monday.
Monday, Monday.
Don't worry.
I'm not throwing Harvest away.
We will play more Harvest.
Harvest on Monday.
Don't worry.
Maybe I'll play this Tuesday or something.
Tuesday.
Okay.
Thank you so much, everybody.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, did I say, let me, oh yeah, I did save.
Okay.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate you hanging out with me.
What's the new sloppy collab?
Oh, well, okay, yeah.
Thanks for bringing that up, actually.
R-DAR, thank you!
Wait, what did it say?
I missed it.
Sorry.
It's my birthday!
Wait, did I say your name right?
R-R-R-DAR?
Radar?
Happy birthday!
Um, yeah, tomorrow is a sloppy sister collab, and the game that I wanted us to play, um, is up to five players, so I was like, and Nimi has asked before, she was like, if you ever need an extra person, for a game when you guys are playing and stuff, um,
feel free to invite me, and so I was just like, well, it's up to five players, so I was like, I'll invite Nimi.
but the dev of the game and the game is supposed to come out tomorrow but the dev of the game said that it might be delayed so we might have to change games but we'll figure something out apparently there was like something with his with the build that like had to get delayed or something but we're still trying to find a game where all five of us can play So,
because obviously I would feel so bad if I was like, hey, Nimmy, you want to play with us?
And then I was like, oh, sorry, Nimmy, we found the game is a big, big delay.
And so we, you know, be so sad.
Sloppy Sisters Unlimited.
Yeah.
So Sloppy Sisters with a side of Nimmy for eyes.
So we're going to find something else.
If the game is not out, we'll see.
Yeah.
But we have plans.
We have ideas for other games.
It's just a matter of choosing something.
But yeah, so the game might be different.
But anyway, thank you guys again.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you had fun.
I had fun and I will see you when I see you next.
Otsumi-do-it-a-shai.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye.
Thank you.
Thanks for watching.
Thanks for hanging out with me.
I really, really appreciate it.
Bye-bye!